today
is our mega
makeover hour we're teaming up with the
biggest names in the beauty industry to
make over not one not two
not three
but 25 amazing deserving women all
show
long
[Applause]
i'm so excited to see how you guys all
look but as we discussed we had a pep
talk backstage and you know what beauty
where it really lives is here and here
this is who we are this is what we've
got and this is what we work with
all right i'm sending all the ladies
backstage are you ready
[Applause]
please welcome drew barrymore
[Applause]
hello everyone
we are so excited that you are all here
we've all been getting to know each
other and it's awesome
this is our mega makeover hour
it's packed with big surprises insider
secrets plus those 25 transformations
that we're gonna have to see to believe
and we'll be checking in with them
throughout the show they're getting
their hair makeup and all new clothes
welcome back to our mega makeover hour
it is time for the big reveal
here they are before
and here they are now come on out ladies
[Applause]
you look so beautiful you look so
beautiful
oh my gosh you look so
[Applause]
gorgeous oh my goodness oh
my gosh
your eyebrows look amazing i love them
oh my gosh
wow
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
i mean
i'm just so happy to be in a sisterhood
with you guys
and it's not just about the hair makeup
and wardrobe it is in your energy
wow
well i want to say thank you to the gap
for dressing all of our women today
i mean
this does not look like it came from one
establishment i love that you could do
all of this in one place i'm there
and um they're also giving all of our
women gift cards today so they can go
back and shop for themselves
200 gift cards each
that's going to be great and um i really
want to thank all of the women from
ready to empower
yes
a world of pink
914 cares
and the theodora de young community
center
and let's not forget about food bank for
nyc
[Applause]
we appreciate all that you do and that's
why we'll be making a donation to all of
your organizations
and absolutely and
i just want to thank this amazing dream
team um to me i am star struck by you
guys
because i'm always watching what you do
out in the world with these like amazing
people but you are amazing people
and i just you know what
it is about the way you feel
and we have got to make ourselves feel
good we've got to make each other feel
good and
i think that this has been very powerful
for me to see a large
[Applause]
group the world isn't easy out there and
if we can have this kind of goodness in
here it gives me the faith and the
belief that i need to just
keep being positive and optimistic so
thank you to everybody chris appleton
francis daniels
santa roberts rusty and the young
emperors nelson tv again and isabelle
shapoo
wow we'll see you all tomorrow
[Music]